bonsoir à tous je vous présente le
botteur stick
qu'est ce que c'est tout simplement une
petite révolution pour étaler le beurre
sur les tartines pratique facile ludique
mais ce n'est pas le produit qui est une
révolution mais plutôt la façon dont il
a vu le jour il est né dans la tête d'un
collégien de 14 ans qui s'est insurgé
avec ses copains de classe contre la
difficulté à tartiner son pain le matin
alors qu'il se lève toujours à la bourre
pour partir à l'école de la même façon
son nez le bavoir amovible le coup tox
simply child et des centaines et des
centaines de produits dans les écoles de
notre région chaque année chaque jour
près de 6000 jeunes travaillent avec
leurs enseignants ils sont collégiens ou
lycéens
ils ont entre 10 et 22 ans il invente
avec leurs enseignants un produit qu'ils
mettent en vente en créant leur mini
entreprise avec l'aide de l'association
entreprendre pour apprendre cette
association a une conviction c'est
ensemble et par la capacité des jeunes à
entreprendre que nous relèverons les
défis économiques qui nous attendent je
dirige cette association depuis dix ans
je suis fille d'un expert comptable
j'ai grandi au rythme des déclarations
sociales et des déclarations fiscales
surtout j'ai vu passer à la maison des
dizaines et des dizaines d'entrepreneurs
tous passionnés par leur métier n'est
jamais imaginé qu'on puisse s'ennuyer
dans sa vie professionnelle j'ai
commencé ma carrière dans une structure
d'insertion pour accompagner les
porteurs de projets dans leurs créations
d'entreprises j ai découvert à quel
point l'entrepreneuriat peut être un
faire une formidable vecteur
d'intégration sociale
c'est dans cet état d'esprit que j'ai
créé l'association entreprendre pour
apprendre
avec l'aide de chefs d'entreprise et
d'enseignants tous convaincus que
l'entrepreneur ya peut-être et doit être
accessible à tous depuis dix ans nous
avons accompagné près de trente mille
jeunes dans la découverte de
l'entrepreneuriat dans les années qui
viennent
neuf mille d'entre eux deviendront
créateurs d'entreprise aujourd'hui
chaque jeune nos enfants vos enfants
doivent grandir avec deux chiffres en
fait le premier c'est que 60% d'entre
eux feront un métier qui n'existe pas
encore ils auront dans leur vie
professionnelle
onze métiers différents c'est dire toute
l'énergie la créativité l'audace et
l'adaptabilité dont ils devront faire
preuve pour imaginer des métiers qui
n'existent pas ils seront flash mobbers
diatta diététiciens c'est même
impossible à dire dataviz heures
agriculteurs dromadaires voilà voilà ce
qu'ils feront demain c'est dire donc
toute la créativité l'audace
l'adaptabilité dont ils devront faire
preuve pour construire le monde dans
lequel ils vont vivre c'est le coeur de
métier de l'association entreprendre
pour apprendre permettre à des jeunes de
stimuler leur énergie entrepreneuriale
pour créer et pour contribuer au monde
de demain aujourd'hui à l'école il ne
suffit plus d'apprendre à développer des
savoirs et des savoir-faire mais surtout
d'acquérir un état d'esprit que
finalement chacun d'entre nous a en lui
mais qui n'émergent pas naturellement si
on ne stimule pas si on n'entretient pas
entreprendre pour apprendre propose
quatre programmes pédagogiques aux
enseignants
nous leur permettons avec ses quatre
programmes d'imaginer et de construire
un parcours pour permettre aux jeunes
d'apprendre progressivement à
entreprendre
parce que nous savons de manière
scientifique qu'un jeune doit vivre dix
expériences entrepreneuriales pour
devenir un adulte entreprenants et parce
que nous sommes convaincus qu
entreprendre c'est comme le vélo ça
s'apprend dès le plus jeune âge ça ne
s'oublie pas nous proposons aux et aux
enseignants des programmes depuis
l'école primaire
jusqu'à l'enseignement supérieur notre
méthode pédagogique s'appuie sur deux
piliers le premier c'est que
l'enseignant accepte d'invités dans sa
classe des personnes qui ont quitté
l'école depuis bien longtemps avec
entreprendre pour apprendre des chefs
d'entreprise des cadres dirigeants et
salariés des bénévoles des retraités et
même des représentants syndicaux rentrer
dans la classe pour travailler avec les
jeunes
il s'agit de construire avec eux un
projet à caractère économique avec
entreprendre pour apprendre il n'y a
plus de face à face pédagogique
nous sommes au coude à coude le deuxième
pilier note de notre pédagogie c'est
d'apporter des méthodes de travail
collaboratives nos animeront des séances
de créativité ou feront du coaching
collectif ou individuel et nous
apporterons des méthodes de travail qui
ont fait leurs preuves en entreprise
l'enseignant s'en inspirera pour
enrichir ses pratiques pédagogiques
traditionnel chaque jour notre équipe un
défi à relever elle jongle entre les
entre des cultures et des codes sociaux
différents
nous jonglons entre les réseaux sociaux
des jeunes
les conseils de direction des chefs
d'entreprise et les conseils de classes
des enseignants
chaque jour nous faisons en sorte que de
nouvelles façons de travailler
émergent que de nouvelles façons de
penser émergent
ce que nous savons c'est que les trente
mille jeunes que nous avons accompagné
les 1500 enseignants qui nous ont fait
confiance et les 800 chefs d'entreprise
qui nous ont accordé du temps ont tous
vécu une aventure exceptionnelle
ensemble ils ont découvert de nouvelles
pratiques de travail
le chef d'entreprise découvre
l'enseignement comme il ne l'a jamais vu
l'enseignement l'enseignant pardon
découvre de nouvelles pratiques dont
certaines sont peut-être plus adapté aux
besoins de chaque individu dans la
classe et le jeune enfin apprend avec
enthousiasme avec insouciance
aujourd'hui j'ai une pensée pour les uns
les rites enseignante elle a découvert
en créant sa mini entreprise avec ses
élèves
que michael n'était pas seulement un
élève délinquants mais qu'il était aussi
un jeune talentueux passionné de dessin
est trilingue
j'ai une pensée pour thierry qui a
accompagné cette année en tant que chef
d'entreprise un projet construit par des
jeunes en situation de handicap car il
n'avait jamais imaginé en septembre 2015
quand il a démarré l'aventuré qu'ils se
retrouveraient sur scène au concours
national des mini-entreprises avec son
équipe dont la moitié
même les trois quarts étaient en
fauteuil roulant j'ai une pensée pour
caroline et surtout pour les parents de
caroline caroline il ya huit ans était
en décrochage de scolaires se parent
était désespérée aujourd'hui ses parents
peuvent en être fiers
caroline est ingénieur en aéronautique
et si demain vous allez sur le parc
mosaïc
n'hésitez pas à rentrer dans la
boulangerie à houplin ancoisne en
sortant du parc
vous y serez accueillis par aurélien
aurélien est un ancien ministre preneur
mais il a fait une mini entreprise il a
8 ans il a repris cette boulangerie il y
a 6 ans c'est le premier effet kiss cool
d' entreprendre pour apprendre le
deuxième effet kiss cool c'est de
contribuer un système entrepreneurial en
pleine effervescence
aujourd'hui nous savons vous et moi qui
ne s'agit plus d'une crise économique
nous sommes dans un système nouveau avec
de nouvelles choses qui émergent mais
nous ne savons pas ce que c'est
entreprendre pour apprendre souhaite
apporter sa pierre à l'édifice nous nous
appuyons sur les besoins sur les
attentes sur les envies des jeunes sur
leur envie de renouveau nous faisons en
sorte que les valeurs de l'enseignement
enfin rejoignent les valeurs de
l'entreprise et vice versa nous faisons
en sorte que la discipline
l'exigence rejoignent les valeurs de
liberté d'indépendance que souhaitent
les entrepreneurs nous faisons en sorte
que les choses ne s'opposent plus mais
qu'elles soient de plus en plus
complémentaires avec un objectif faire
émerger un monde empreint d'humanisme de
citoyenneté de respect mutuel c'est de
cette façon que nous avons construit
l'association entreprendre pour
apprendre parce qu'aujourd'hui il ne
s'agit plus de dissocier mais bien de
réunir
cette association aurait pu prendre une
autre couleur elle est membre d'un
réseau européen qui propose des
programmes pédagogiques partout en
europe
dans le nord pas de calais nous lui
avons donné une couleur particulière
elle est construite cette association
avec des personnes des entrepreneurs des
responsables associatifs avec des
enseignants avec des chefs
d'établissement avec des jeunes aussi
qui tous les jours ne rejoigne et qui
sont empreintes d'une forte culture
entrepreneuriale
les fondateurs de cette association ont
tous en commun la conviction que
l'entreprise est un acteur clé du
territoire ils ont tous aussi pour souci
que chaque jeune trouve sa place dans la
société
en respectant son chemin en respectant
son histoire en respectant sa propre
ambition c'est pour cette raison dans
l'association nous avons écrit trois
valeurs l'ambition le sens de la
relation et l'engagement avec un
objectif porté par chacun d'entre nous
de rendre au territoire ce que nous
avons reçu aujourd'hui l'association est
fière du chemin qu'elle a parcouru
nous avons sensibilisé trente mille
jeunes nous travaillons avec des
entrepreneurs fidèles avec des
enseignants avec des bénévoles mais nous
savons aussi que tout reste à faire
seulement 5% de la génération sur la
région nord pas de calais bénéficient de
ce type de dispositif ailleurs en europe
c'est 60% en moyenne
nous savons par des calculs
scientifiques que nous avons menées au
sein de l'association que si nous avions
une mini entreprise par établissement
scolaire que 6e chaque enseignant
s'engager dans un parcours
entrepreneurial
demain nous aurions une région au de
france qui compte sur la scène
internationale aujourd'hui il exerce à
ma manière
le métier que je rêvais de faire quand
j'étais petite je rêvais d'être pianiste
accompagnatrice pas seulement pianiste
mais bien pianiste accompagnatrice parce
qu'un pianiste accompagnateur doit non
seulement maîtriser son instrument le
solfège et la musique
mais il doit aussi et surtout être à
l'écouté de l'autre et à l écoute du
soliste qui l'accompagnent un pianiste
accompagnateur doit faire preuve
d'abnégation de force de proposition et
de force de caractère
et doivent à doivent avoir un sens de la
diplomatie ce sont les talents nous
demandons aux permanents de
l'association et aux personnes qui
jouissent qui nous rejoignent et qui
s'engagent à nos côtés
parce que pour accompagner des jeunes
dans leur développement pour être à
l'écouté des entrepreneurs qui nous
donne du temps et pour être à l'écouté
des besoins des enseignants
il faut effectivement faire preuve
d'abnégation de force de caractère et de
sens de diplomatie
si aujourd'hui je devais résumer
l'action d'entreprendre pour apprendre
cela résoudrait de la manière suivante
nous sommes des initiateurs des
catalyseurs des facilitateurs
finalement nous ne faisons pas grand
chose nous faisons juste en sorte que
des mondes se réunissent alors qu'ils se
regardent plutôt en parallèle pour
l'instant nous faisons en sorte que les
jeunes découvrent leur parcours
découvrent leur chemin de vie faisons en
sorte que chacun avance à sa manière
avec ses talents et nous faisons en
sorte surtout qu'il identifie ses
talents délai dès le plus jeune âge mais
tout cela ne pourrait pas exister sans
la passion et l'énergie des chefs
d'entreprise et des enseignants qui
travaillent à nos côtés ce sont eux et
finalement qui au quotidien font de
boulot auprès des jeunes
s'il ya des chefs d'entreprise et des
enseignants dans la salle j'ai juste
envie de leur dire bravo et merci